in the movie the dark knight by
christopher nolan
there are many powerfully constructed
scenes which are almost mini stories in
themselves
as the movie reaches its crescendo
there's a scene where it appears that
the joker's clowns
have taken doctors as hostages of course
being a joker ploy
the situation hides a trick and an
inversion
the way batman deals with this situation
can help us understand
what it means to be a hero in an upside
down world this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
the trick being played in the scene is
indeed the setup of an upside down
threat
although appearing as aggressors and
instigators of chaos
it is in fact the clowns who are taken
hostage
gagged under their mask while the
doctors representatives of goodness
order and healing are the kidnappers
hoping
to ambush the police as they attempt to
restore order
this scene batman has an insight that
the others don't have
he can see the truth hiding behind
appearances he can perceive that the
world is upside down
this is of course shown by him having
glowing eyes
with light representing the inside which
he has over the police
so batman realizes that this situation
makes obeying those in authority
impossible for the time being
so not only does he disobey the police
but he actively attacks them
he prevents them from harming the clowns
who are in fact victims
in disguise so by attacking police
he's not only protecting the hostages
but he's actually protecting
the police themselves though we have no
way of knowing that
at the moment so without knowing it the
police are
in danger of compromising themselves by
killing innocent victims
and they're also in danger of being
ambushed and killed by the kidnappers
who are dressed as doctors
but from the perspective of the police
batman is helping the kidnappers
and so they soon turned their hostility
towards him
as well by all appearances batman is now
their enemy
though secretly he is helping them in
many ways this is one of the best
examples that i can call to mind of what
i mean when i use the
term double inversion and how an upside
down world can
only be restored to normality by a
second inversion
batman makes himself an enemy of a
corrupted order
in order to restore a proper one but for
a moment
the moment of transition this is evident
only to batman
now this type of social game with the
clowns and doctor orchestrated by the
joker
is in fact what motivates him what the
joker wants
is to make a point it's not about money
it's about spending a message
he wants to expose the corruption and
chaos of the world
to expose the darkness and show that it
is in fact the darkness which rules over
the light
upset the established order and
everything
becomes chaos the appearance of water
and hierarchy are illusions in his
vision
a deceptive veneer that can be scratched
away to reveal
the abyss which truly motivates reality
as he says when the chips are down
these uh these civilized people
they'll eat each other he's an
evangelical
nihilist that's why he wants to turn
harvey dent
this is the point of the standoff at the
ferry
and this is also the point right here by
duping batman and the police
into killing innocent people now this
whole situation is a
very dangerous one ethically i mean how
many people have you met
who feel that they have ample reason to
break the rules or to act against
authority
and how many times has you yourself felt
that same self-righteousness
within yourself i mean doesn't every
rebel criminal
tax evader and insurgent feel like he
has good reason
for breaking the rules and acting
against the authority
so what makes batman's action different
from the action of
some other mere rebel so the first
argument that
comes is the most obvious one he's doing
this for others to help the hostages
so this is a good start but it lacks
something
i'm sure stalin and robespierre all
believe they were acting for the good of
others
or better still the good of even those
against whom their actions
were immediately directed because just
like robespierre batman is acting for
the good of the police who he is
actively attacking
so another angle which can help us
understand is that batman
unlike stalin or robespierre is not
trying to gain power for himself
or some ideology that he represents his
actions are not meant
to make him the mayor or the chief of
police and so it's not a revolution in
that sense
he's also not trying to promote some
ideology at the expense
of those being attacked but through all
of this
it is in my last and most important
argument which lies the secret
what batman is doing leads to an act of
self-sacrifice
after attacking the police and becoming
their target he doesn't try to defend
himself in fact
he takes the blame on himself and not
only
for his own sins but he even tries to
carry the sins of harvey dent
ultimately he can't i killed those
people
that's what i can be no no you can't
you're not
whatever god needs me to be so even
though he's innocent
batman submits to the current authority
and says that he must be hunted
and that the dogs must be set on him he
carries the consequences of his actions
and doesn't attempt to be vindicated he
shows no self-righteousness though you
know he would have had every right
to call on his innocence to those
attacking him
this is what justifies batman's
rebellion so it's these three elements
coming together number one acting to
help others
number two not acting to gain power for
oneself or some ideology
number three willing to sacrifice
oneself and accept the consequences
of our actions this story shows a
surprising parallel with another more
famous
anecdote it's the story of christ
clearing the temple
from money changers and animals so this
story
has often been used to portray christ as
a kind of revolutionary
but in fact we will see that it is not
at all the case
that christ is balancing out all these
elements that i mentioned
of how to act in an upside down world
so christ is facing a corrupt structure
the purpose of the temple which has the
highest purpose that one can imagine
has been diverted a place meant to be
the house of god
a place of purity of hierarchy and
ultimately the center of jewish society
and identity
has been given over to greed and
corruption
so we find moral compromise but also
money changing
itself shouldn't happen in the temple
this is a little more complicated to
understand but
money changing is the opposite of purity
money changing is something like the
interchangeability of identity
a place of flux where one identity moves
into another where identity is reduced
to quantity
and where what is inside and what is
strange move into each other very easily
so money changing should happen in a
market or near the wall of a city
but certainly it has no room in a space
meant for hierarchy and purity
the money changer story is also dealing
with animality this idea
that animals the garments of skin
shouldn't be our prime concern
on an individual level the animal part
of us should be kept out of the heart we
could say
which is why the story has often been an
image of the taming of the
strange thoughts and the passions from
the inner sanctum of the bodily temple
so christ purifies the temple cleans it
of
impurity animality and immorality
he is doing this to heal the temple just
like he cast out demons in the possessed
man or
disease in the sick so he's acting to
help israel
and therefore he fulfills the first
aspect of the hero in the upside-down
world that i mentioned
he's acting to help others but in doing
this he's also acting in opposition to
the corrupt leadership of the temple
and possibly the roman authority as well
in fact they think that christ is doing
this in order to claim some authority
for himself
to become king but christ says he's
acting in the name of the father
and not for his own glory he's also
not trying to instinct to install
something new he just wants to restore
the proper order
that should already have been there he's
acting
against the the present lower authority
in order to restore
some higher authority which those
currently in power
are blind to and this is also what
batman is doing in the hostage situation
but let's be honest it's also the claim
of many of reformers many
revolutionaries
and insurgents almost all people who
take power and oppose current structures
claim to do so to restore a higher more
ancient or pure version
of authority though secretly they also
want to claim power for themselves
and so the question of the second rule
of not wanting
to gain power for oneself or some
ideology is answered
by the third willing to sacrifice
oneself
and accept the consequences of our
actions
the cleansing of the temple is the event
which sets in motion the crucifixion of
christ
but when he is arrested when he is
judged by a corrupt system
when he is condemned to die he does not
protest
he does not call upon his followers to
fight and does not attempt
to usurp the current structure he was
willing to act against the authorities
to do
what was right when these authorities
were wrong
but he also accepted the consequence
and did not cause a political revolution
by acting this way christ was in fact
planting a seed
a seed which would grow in secret and
would flourish to overturn
and transform the roman empire not from
without like an
invasion or a revolution but from within
like a transformation
of the heart and the growing of a mighty
tree
and this is not just some moralization
that i'm trying to do but is in fact
revealing the very structure of reality
we have seen what the revolutions of the
modern world have brought about
when one sets oneself up in power
through revolution and makes you
vulnerable
to others to do the same to you and so
this leads to succeeding breakdowns
and tyrannies which the culture of
demand and protest inevitably bring
about
so this mode of action the one
exemplified by christ
and maybe more imperfectly by batman as
well
is the only one which can ultimately
produce true transformation so this
lesson is a hard one to accept
nearly impossible but i think it is
nonetheless something to ponder
as the world becomes increasingly mad
increasingly corrupt and upside down and
we all wonder
what to do as we watch it break apart
around us
if you enjoyed this content and our
exploration of symbolism
get involved i love to read your
insights and questions in the comments
section
you can also share this video on social
media to your friends
and if you can please consider
supporting us financially
through patreon or paypal you'll find
those links in the description below
you